for real like i'm not even playing with
you won't even like it
what don't say that don't say that
don't say that you are so pretty
you are gonna
you when you look at yourself you
supposed to say i'm so pretty you are
so pretty do you hear me you got the
prettiest little dimples
you are too cute
no you make me cry you're not obviously
girl
oh my god
you're not ugly
[Music]
baby girl
you are so pretty you are like you have
this beautiful chocolate skin
like you are just so gorgeous you got
these dimples she didn't even think it
was that bad
what she said she didn't think that what
she said was that bad
because she didn't realize uh i'm ugly
she just said that like that
she started feeling some type of weight
because the lady that's there that's
braiding her head she
had a reaction and kids are very
sensitive to people's hands yeah exactly
not so much that i didn't mean to do
something bad i did something bad i
didn't mean to do something better now
you're having a reaction
i did that and then it's all that that's
what happened
but at first she was just saying that
like that there wouldn't
be one tear or nothing like that because
she's used to that that she's been
feeling like that
for a while now you know what else no
you're not gonna cry you are a beautiful
little girl
and you are pretty you are the prettiest
girl in your class
boom tell them straight up when you go
to school tomorrow you got your hair
done
you gonna be like oh look at my hair oh
look at my shoes look at my clothes baby
girl you are beautiful black is
beautiful and if don't nobody ever tell
you
i will tell you you are gorgeous you are
so pretty
and you're going to grow up and you're
going to be everything that you can be
you're going to be the greatest nail
tech the greatest beautician the
greatest lawyer the greatest doctor the
greatest teacher
whatever you want to be the greatest
speaker the greatest
entrepreneur whatever what you want to
be which one do you get older
uh you want to be
your teacher mean to you so guess what
when you become a teacher
you don't be mean you'll be a nice
teacher you'll be
you gonna be miss miss cotton that's
they're gonna call you
you hold your head up
you hold your head up okay
okay have a hug
i love you guys just almost made me cry
alive
uh um turn this way
girl you just almost made me cry ariana
you can't be doing stuff like that you
gotta warn me
baby you just said that like a grown
woman that's going through things
whoa god in the name of jesus
i understand why she would say something
like that what do you mean
i was that little girl back when i was a
kid i remember one day
um feeling out how i was feeling because
of certain events and whatever what not
i was sitting on my bed my dad passed
right by my door and he's like yo what
is this
and thought like right in front of my
bed there was there was a wall and i
wrote with duct tape
uh you are ugly and that's the first
thing i used to see when i used to wake
up in the morning
you are ugly i used to see that i wrote
that
that's how i felt that's the truth
that's the truth to me so it was what it
was it's pretty creative though not more
it is with duct tape i mean you could
use a mark or anything like that but you
also
know i don't want to get my who my
that's right
so you still got it on the wall i'm not
stupid i'm ugly
hey hey yeah you remove that you there's
no problem you know what i mean
i thought i was ugly not stupid i'm not
going to finish again my ass would
because of some feelings i feel
i feel you i meant i
try to get my whoop i already feel ugly
not getting
you're ugly my dad was like oh oh what
what is this
like uh something i wrote
he's like started to have a conversation
with me and that was i was grateful with
that because my camera
my parents always had conversations with
me my dad was like yo you have to be
really careful with the words the words
they mean something
they really mean something like you
can't wake up
and see words like that you're gonna go
into a
spiral and you're gonna spiral down
there's a lot of complicated things that
i cannot tell you right now because
you're not old enough but
nah that's not really the good way about
going things if you feel things like
that you should come see me
your sister or your mom or whatever you
need to talk about it but
i'm gonna ask you to remove just remove
that just take it off
and you watch me take it off make sure i
took it off and i took it off but at
some point
when i was growing up it was like that i
always say that yo i used to grow up i
was an ugly
kid it's not so much that i was ugly or
not i was up not the standards
i was not what it was even if she sees
black people around her but the black
people they got what they got the air
extensions they got blonde
color in their eyes and stuff like that
she doesn't have those features
well there's a study that they did where
they asked like toddlers what they
thought was beautiful between a black
and a white princess yeah
like all the kids chose the white one
because even at their age they
internalize blackness
what is mean what is ugly what is they
know what
the dark is bad and good that's that's
called i think it's a
with a doll experiment or something like
that yeah and it's been replicated a few
times i mean i'll post a link to it
uh i'd seen that a long time ago so i'm
not sure how if it still stands but i
probably believe it does
why did you grow up thinking that you
were unattractive listen i was
i live in a white country in a white
province in a white neighborhood
in a white white white white white
everything
and the standards was not black
it was not so by definition i was not
the standard
so i was not pretty much that looked
like me was rejecting me so i'm like all
right cool
i'm talking guys and girls to be friends
or not the guys they thought i was too
white
and the girls didn't think i i was not
manly enough i was not enough of
anything
i was never enough so i get that it's
just like at some point
past the phase when you want to delete
yourself because there was a point where
it was like that
for numerous reasons i came in this
other opposite that
i appropriated my ugliness that's why i
am that's who i am
and i can't change anything about that
so i want a different route you know
what i mean
but i understand that little girl and
the thing that happened is that she's
four the problem
solving aspect of your brain is not
that developed it's not there it's not
fully
grown you know i mean so what happened
is that your solution is not
it's not as violent as whenever
we think death is you know what i mean
that's not what it is for a kid
that does that to themselves that
deletes themselves that self-delete
it's not as violent what they see and
what they understand i know that because
i've been there
what they understand is this
they understand basic math if i have me
and i'm the problem and i have this
society if i remove myself from the
equation
no problem i don't fit nowhere so
there's no problem to them is just the
easiest way to solve a solution
if it doesn't work you take it out
they just do what they do because they
just want to stop
hurting is this how life is really and
they just do what they do
i'm not even advocating for that and
there's other solutions
but i do understand where they're coming
from you know what else
when i was watching this she kept
looking towards the the phone
knowing it was being live streamed like
she's keenly aware that people are
observing her
and it matters to her so even as the
woman was giving her a pep talk and
being like you're beautiful
i kept seeing her trying to look back at
the phone to see what the people were
saying is that because you're getting
schooled in front of people you're like
you know when you're getting it beat
sometimes you know my aunts they used to
come to my house and i did something bad
and that would not stop the beating
my mom from beating my in front of her
sister and look this is in no way
i was trying to say that we necessarily
understand completely what it's like to
be a black woman or anything like that
that being said i think whenever
anyone's watching something
they try to internalize it through their
own experiences and that's how they try
to create a
empathetic bond and so we as men may not
live the same experience but we're going
to try to draw on our own experiences of
being told we're unattractive and ugly
to try to relate and to try to
understand it's just important to note
that that experience is never
necessarily a substitute for another
person's
trajectory in life does that make sense
yeah i understand but you know why she
said she was ugly she was looking at the
camera
because she didn't want to get
necessarily filmed she's like yo you
filming me while i'm there and i'm uh
i'm ugly why are you filming me like
that's what i understand that's what you
took it out
but when she said i'm ugly she was
looking directly at the camera
yeah like why are you doing this why are
you filming me when you putting me on
the spot i'm ugly
right another thing that stood out to me
is when she mentioned that her teacher
was me what you want to be which one do
you get older
oh good teacher you want to be
y'all teacher mean to you often times
it's really the
adults around you and the people around
you that really inform your opinion of
yourself when you're a child
i informed my opinion of me based off of
the people around me when i was a kid
my rejections everyone kind of avoiding
me so
just telling to me that she has that
same experience listen
go ahead i said that to you already man
when i was a kid i was bullied but the
people that believed me the most were my
teachers yeah that's the worst part
though
like i don't think they recognize
sometimes how heavily they
impact people and how selfish which is
why like a good teacher
can change your life and a bad teacher
can ruin it absolutely yeah
a bad teacher can mess it up shout out
to a career longer
i see your mother it was just
bad bad so yeah it can make you can
break you teachers do have an important
like
role yeah it's like you see a lot of
your parents and then you see a lot of
you teachers the whole year
yeah it's a vocation it's not a jobby
job
you don't become a teacher because it's
your third pick and if you do
you probably shouldn't be there i always
tell this like i had multiple
successive bad teachers but i remember
had one that really turned it around for
me
and i just remember them being like
breath i see you sleep in my class all
the time but you're far more intelligent
than you let on
just pay the attention because you have
the potential right and i remember that
always stuck with me
and i didn't realize to what point until
i was probably in my
early 20s and i was thinking about what
i wanted to do after the military
and part of me all of a sudden wanted to
become a teacher more particularly a
history teacher
why do i want to teach i mean i love
history but not that much and then it
dawned on me the person that really
affected me
was a history teacher i wanted to do for
other kids what i felt like that teacher
had done for me
and i think that always stuck with me so
i always said if i wasn't doing this
stuff and i was going back to school it
would be to teach
like i could name the dope teachers that
i had yes
yeah you remember i remember they marked
you like that yeah yeah
same here i can definitely say that and
i think the last thing i wanted to touch
on was
you know when you're watching this you
might understand like oh i've been told
i'm ugly i think for black people
uh the and maybe other groups as well
um this video kind of highlights why
representation matters because often
times
you know your environment can tell you
you're ugly and that's one thing but
when all the images that you see your
favorite cartoons
everything that you're watching on
television is also reinforcing that idea
it's hard to get away from it that's why
even though i personally
didn't like black panther i understood
why it was so important for a lot of
african-americans and black people in
general
because they really appreciated just
seeing themselves
in a different light that's why i'm a
hero yeah absolutely
yeah it's even like you know men when we
see fathers in a lot of movies and
there's always like some dalty like
oh i don't know how to take care of the
kids where do i get the diapers right
it gets annoying to see that
representation because it starts to
affect you just and then you saw uncle
phil rule someone
right right and so when you hear a
healthy representation of fatherhood
it makes you appreciative the same token
black people just seeing themselves in a
positive light we feel some type of way
often times
i mean even me the other day i remember
i was watching burner boys win as uh you
know grammy award as an african even
though i'm not nigerian it did make me
feel pleasure
seeing african music highlighting that
way i'm like oh even you know
on that level it feels good yeah it
doesn't necessarily mean that's
my victory that being said it does i
hope it just
inks in the mind of people the
possibility you know the more you see
yourself in that position the more
likely
if you can visualize it you're more
likely to get there does that make sense
yeah it's a bit
when people come and see us and say that
to us too they see something that we
don't necessarily see yeah
like they see something else i'm like oh
i'm glad we could do that for you i'm
happy that
that to bring you that that joy i guess
yeah yeah it's i get that little girl i
get all of that
i got it it's pretty much it for today's
video moral of the story is
um if you think you're ugly just write
it on your wall with scotch tape
okay don't use markers no because you
won't get your ass
and uh yeah that's pretty much it we
want to hear your comments and thought
below what do you think about this
video your experience with yourself
still we want to hear all about that
so that's it
[Music]
you got two dimples i don't even have
two dimples
you know i was making me laugh because
that's the kind of [ __ ] that you try to
come up with to cheer the kid up so
you'll be saying anything
but she's doing a good job who got
through the impulse
i do they don't even know that your
nickname is dimples yeah my my dad's
nickname
yeah yeah his dancer named duncan people
don't know that
so based off like what name you use
that's where he knows you from that's
yeah
yeah i got different names from
different places yeah and if you call me
on the street when you call me by a
certain name i'm like
i know that person from that thing yeah
i know that person from that thing i
know
that person from that circle yeah all
right i'll just keep playing i don't
want to comment on the subject yet